[Music]
[Music]
I'm Jeremy Brock
welcome to the BAFTA and BFI
international screenwriters lecture
series for 2013 I was on the BAFTA Film
Committee and discovered I was the only
screenwriter who'd ever been on it
and after I got over the shock I decided
that the best I could do for my
screenwriting brothers and sisters was
to set up a lecture series in the name
of BAFTA and we were able to bring the
BFI in on that this year we've got a
fantastic lineup we start with David s
Goyer we end with Richard Curtis and in
between we have Hossein Amini Susannah
grant and Tony Gilroy
these are serious heavyweights from the
UK and from America you will be inspired
by these individuals in Hollywood
executives tend to divide writers up
into types I think the very best writers
aren't a type I think they bring every
skill and I think Tony is a really good
example of a true renaissance writer to
those in the community he is famous for
his ability to write incredibly terse
incredibly powerful dialogue and to
imbue action with an authority in a
power that stops it feeling like yet
another car chase he brings an
incredibly potent mix of very male
muscularity to his work and it's there
in the person it's there in Tony but at
the same time he's got an incredibly
enquiring mind incredible curiosity and
that ability to be curious about the
world and how people work is what gives
even his most blockbuster II characters
a complexity which is rare in big temple
movies I think Tony will shy away from
nothing I think he will tell it as it is
and I think that's a really useful
lesson for aspiring writers I've been
hoping to get Tony Gilroy for a very
long time so it's a huge pleasure to be
introducing Tony Gilroy other than about
a 10-year period of my life where I was
deeply harnessed to the service economy
everything I've ever had in my life that
I've been given or that I've given to my
family has been the result of somebody
making stuff up that people would play
at in front of a camera everything I
sold my first screenplay when I was 30
and in that time since then I pretty
much done every single kind of
screenwriting job that that you can do
from sort of page one blank page all the
way through to a premiere to a one day
dialogue polish for an actor you'll
never meet an a you know a director on
the phone everything in between every
now and then something comes up that
it's some wacky permutation on
unemployment but the entire kama sutra
of hollywood experience i have i have
assumed both positions as a screenwriter
top and bottom so what should we talk
about tonight in light of all of that
I've looked at the others I think what I
want to talk about tonight is I wanna
talk about the original screenplay
because that's what I've spent the bulk
of my life doing and that's how I think
of myself and it's the thing I think I
know the most about I'm writing an
original now I'm supposed to be
finishing it I've been on it just vastly
too long I've ignored most of the things
I'm gonna tell you tonight
which is why this lecture is for me as
much as you two remind me of what a you
know what an [ __ ] I am for ignoring
my own rules and and I'm serious about
that and so I'll talk I'll try to be
brief and I'm gonna try to talk about
how to build an original screenplay and
in in not the pixie dust kind of way and
and not too technical at the same time
I'll clarify one thing I'm not really an
adapter I have there's just been books
I've chased over the years so they
really wanted to be involved with that
if I'd ever got my hands on them I would
have done a very been a very a very
zealous protector of the books I've only
done one book that Dolores Claiborne we
did and we changed significantly
change the structure of the book and the
telling of it but in the end I think was
a really successful adaptation it really
it captured the Stephen King's world and
the character and it really is faithful
in a really in a really molecular kind
of way and I know Stephen King I've
heard this even King it's one of his
favorite ones and so in that sense we
were very responsible the rest the
adaptation credits I have or quite
honestly fig leaves I mean they're
they're really they're really I've never
read a Robert Ludlum novel ever I don't
know how many I've written I don't know
15 20 I didn't want to count because I
didn't want to be depressed about how
many of them hadn't gotten made and and
that's really the reason I don't want
again I mean so let's so here we go so
we're let's I'm trying to think how to
do this hey we're sort of in this
together
so there's nothing there's absolutely
nothing and there has to be a movie and
so so what do you do I mean there has to
be from the sheer directed force of
imagination something has to happen and
if there's any single theme from tonight
that would be a value I would want you
to leave here being reminded or
confirmed that this is imaginative work
we make stuff up and it's it's not you
know it's not magic mushroom ring
Stonehenge special but we make stuff up
there is a level there's a level of
romance and imagination to this that is
not found in any screenwriting book or
in any seminar or any class or anything
like that
it's unteachable you cannot teach
someone to be imagine
you can't you can't you you can kill it
you know you can sure kill it and it can
be trained and you can you can magnify
it and do all kinds of things but you
can't you can't teach it so that's the
bad news
the good news is we're making an
original screenplay so we're building a
house for the lot you know we're
building a house for a to our we're
building a structure for a for a to our
experience we need we need an idea and
you don't have it I know you have no
ideas for me
we need you need like anything we need a
spark we need some place to start and
for me for us well me will be us now we
need something really small small is
good small is really really good for me
something small and very very specific
and and something that the big ideas
don't work it's it's death if you say
how we want to do cly want me to move
about class warfare or I want to do
maybe about corporate malfeasance so I
want to do moving about power Paradise
you just drown but something really
really small something small that has
access it feels like maybe it has access
to something larger be a character be a
moment in time it can be a situation
between two people it can be a point in
history it could be like anything but
something really really small something
very specific and cutting edge first
movie ever made producer comes to me I'm
desperate to get a movie maybe comes I
want to do a movie about I want you
Taming of shrew in the world of Paris
figure skating man okay I'm there I'll
do that I can do that all right I want a
movie so bad I'll do that now I've
worked so hard not to get fired off that
movie I really said was really I'm gonna
suck it up for a whole whole way through
it could even be stupid technical Steven
Soderbergh and I when we started on
duplicity cuz he was the first person I
started talking about I said you know
Steven I always want to do a movie where
I went to a movie where there's a couple
and they have three scenes but each time
the scene happens it means something
completely different
well that's a little bit odd place to
start but it's specific and it's sort of
keys off a fixer they do move fixer one
day movie a fixer Wow fixer at a law
firm well that's a fascinating you know
that's a pretty that's a pretty
interesting place to start and then what
do i do what do we do so I literally
play with it I put it I said it I sit on
my desk I sit in front of the keyboard
and I just run with it I I write around
it and it's mostly almost entirely
dialogue because the characters have to
rise I don't know how you plot a movie
I've talked to people who plot movies
and work on stuff where they they write
oh this happens then it has to be the
characters have to rise and it has to
come from dialogue for me and the fixer
at the law firm I kept coming back to I
thought well that's a really cool thing
and one day I wrote a scene I probably
went away from it and came back to it
and went away from me came back to it
but I kept writing this I had this scene
that I wrote this hit and run scene
where this guy comes out to well you
know I will show it this is this is from
Michael Clayton and this is a scene that
predates the film by a very long stretch
mr. Greer you left the scene of an
accident on a slow weeknight six miles
from the State Police barracks believe
me if there's a line you're right up
front I can get a lawyer anytime I want
to I don't need you for that we're not
sitting here for 45 minutes waiting for
a goddamn referral I don't know what
Walter promised you but like I'm a
miracle worker
that's Walter on the phone 20 minutes
ago direct quote okay hang tight I'm
sending you a miracle worker he misspoke
about what about the fact that you're
the firmest fixer
unless you're any good at it Elliot the
guy was rioting in the streets you take
that you had the floor yet the lives you
had the angle
what the [ __ ] is he doing running in the
middle of the street at midnight huh you
answer me that
[Applause]
so that sneeze gonna kill me
all right so have that I had that in my
room and I really dig it I really dig
this scene and I start to write around
the possibilities of this and this
project was interrupted many times by
different things and different
circumstances and Bourne interrupted
this project and proof-of-life
interrupted this project but I make the
biggest mess if I told you the versions
of Michael Clayton that I had written
you know that were architected around
this scene I mean there's a version and
outline version is not versions of
giraffes but you know chase down a
version that's all about the Sun and the
fantasy fiction and chased the round of
down a version where there's a love
story with a mistress of a corporate
client that he's trying to extract the
client from and the murderer within the
in the word processing department of the
I mean all kinds of things this mad
Explorer will go on for a very long
period of time and really what has to
happen is the mess really has to stop it
really has to stop someplace and you
really have to say to yourself we have
to say to ourselves where is the movie
where's the movie what is the movie I
have all this stuff you know I'm
building this whole world I need to know
what the movie is about and you cannot
at a certain point you cannot pass go
without doing this and you can get if
you're in the system you can get seduced
pestis because sometimes you're coming
up with a bunch of groovy stuff I was on
suborn supremacy and we got way far down
the row with all this great stuff in the
beginning everybody got all accepted
there was really no movie there and I
was the only one who knew it and they
were building the movie is sort of
designed build we're building at the
same time and were and it's like wow and
it's a fun night to say stop there's we
don't know what the movies about and and
and then of really a great thing came
out of that which was this whole story
of Atonement I had a complete mandate to
throw absolutely everything away I said
in read a Robert Ludlum novel no one
involved in the process I've never read
Robert
I was given a script that was based on a
Robert Ludlum novel and in the course of
basically telling him everything that I
thought was wrong with it an idea came
out and I go wow we really like that and
literally very quickly because it was a
whole celebrity aspect to this there was
a lot of momentum to it that I was given
a really a mandate to throw everything
away and actually do what I understand
is the opposite of what the book is
which is the book was about a guy who is
a good guy who's used as a decoy to be
an assassin for Carlos the Jackal this
was basically said to them the idea that
the movie came out of the very first
meeting was if I if I don't know who I
am and I don't know where I come from I
can only identify myself by the things I
do know how to do and what if I find out
that all the things that I know how to
do are bad day one literally day one on
born at my office waiting for doug liman
to show up for the next day's craziness
I'm there like okay sketching away and a
scene came up it's just a really simple
scene it's beautifully simply acted but
this scene contains the genetic DNA that
will ride all three Matt Damon Jason
Bourne films it's really uh it maybe you
won't seem like much but it really this
I had first and again so it's one of
these towels one of these one of these
scenes you just you cling to so why
don't we show the the Bourne clip who
has a safety deposit box for them
money and six passports and a gun who
has a bank account number in their hip I
come in here and the first thing I'm
doing is I'm catching the sightlines and
looking for an exit I see the exit sign
- I'm not worried I mean you were shot
people do all kinds of weird and amazing
stuff when they're scared I can tell you
the license-plate numbers of all six
cars outside I can tell you that our
waitress is left-handed and the guy
sitting up at the counter weighs 215
pounds and knows how to handle himself I
know the best place to look for a gun is
the cab with a great truck outside and
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking now why would I know that and I
know that not know who I am all right so
we have an idea I mean what the movies
about
and we've made sort of a mess but if
you're gonna make a much much bigger
mess now and we're gonna make a world we
have to make a whole world around all of
this and and that's what this is and
that's the sort of second unteachable
part of this process you know if you
can't teach people to be imaginative you
certainly also can't teach them to know
things that they don't know and and you
hear all the time oh right what you know
and I don't I never I don't know if that
means what you can only you should write
what you've lived which is pretty it
would put a lot of people in the ghetto
of their own existence I think it's
pretty limiting but you can only write
what you know about and what you know
about will limit or open the
possibilities to to everything and
my knowledge my general knowledge of the
world is is incredibly wide and very
very thin dinner dinner companion Finn
but I can go anywhere you know and it
serves me it will serve you really
really well but you're limited by what
you know those one thing that you have
to know that is a deal breaker on all of
it you have to know human behavior you
cannot pass go you cannot move forward
you are dead stopped right here right
now if you do not know human behavior
and the quality of your writing is
absolutely capped at your understanding
of human behavior you'll never write
above what you know about people the
notes that I'm not looking at I have
double star the quality of your writing
will be a direct reflection of your
understanding of the contradictions and
complexities of human behavior I think I
said that but I want to say it again
because it's really just ABS didn't
matter if you're writing for oryx right
or you're writing for Anne Boleyn it
doesn't make any difference it's you
that's it and it's more than
understanding you have to have empathy
you know you have to feel for these
people you have to live because you're
gonna have to live out if you're doing
it right if to live out the movie
through every one of them alright so
we've done all that and we have all this
and we have we know what the movies
about and we're great at human behavior
and we know all kinds of [ __ ] and we're
geniuses and it's all great so now we
have to write an outline and I you know
I've heard writers over the years oh I
don't I don't really like to do outlines
because it's too constricting I think
that's to me the outline I think they're
completely wrong if you go onto
screenplay form and try to figure out
your movie it's like putting on a tuxedo
to go to a diner or something I don't
know what you're doing what do you I
don't want to be in screenplay form
until the bitter end and I'll get to
that at the very end of this thing I do
not want to put on my tuxedo until the
very end I want to continue to make a
mess I want to write an outline now I
want to write the movie the faster we
can do it the better I've done in as
little as four days on Clayton it took
like I think I'm still not done with
Michael
you know and you want to write it to the
end you want to write it to the end and
when you don't you spend the year that I
just spent and what I'm just coming off
right now where I've ignored my own
rules
these documents are they can be 30 50 60
it can be 80 pages long but it is the
whole movie we want this loose ugly but
really proper sorry version of the movie
and you're making the film you're making
this world and it's got to be real to
you as much as you know as I said before
you have to know stuff it has to be real
every scene has to be real and so we're
plotting you know and plotting plotting
a movie it depends if you're plotting a
thriller it is an agony it's it's it's
it's really really it's really shitty
tiresome work sometimes I can't do it
you know I can have big ideas in the
shower but not typically about plotting
I have to sit down I have to sit down
and literally it sounds so stupid I was
thinking about it today as I was gonna
describe either just sit down at the
keyboard and talk to myself I have I
don't know you know thousands of pages
of files of me talking to myself and
some sort of weird Socratic conversation
about you know okay if he does this what
does that mean and then well ABCD we
could do this or that or this and and
then oh my god it I'll write this in
I'll write a scene and dialog will push
me forward for the plot II but it's it's
it's not easy pickins that if it's done
really well for people to know stuff in
a thriller so he knows that and she
knows this but if they don't know that
how does he find out what I mean it's
there's no easy way to do it and you
just beat it you just beat it through so
we have that outline we're done that we
have our 50 60 page outline and we know
what the movies about and how we're
really good we're moving really quickly
too so we're at the end and now it
really is time now I'll go to screenplay
now whatever you know a final draft or
movie magic
whatever it is and now it's it really is
fun it really is for me it's when it's
fun it's when it's precise it's the
great thing about having this document
is when you go to work every day you
don't have to you can build up momentum
you know what you're supposed to do
today and all you're doing is making it
better than you had in the outline
before you're cutting things out all the
time there's really nothing that feels
any better than cutting out something
that you don't need that you thought you
needed even if you spent 20 years
writing it's like well I don't need that
oh my god it feels it feels so good and
energized and you really build up a head
of steam in his final phase and so I
have this final pretty phase where it's
really making this this this this
prettified version and what will
inevitably happen in this pretty flawed
version which is going to happen to me
in two weeks when I when I after I stop
working on what I'm going to say tonight
I'm producing my brothers movie and get
back to what I'm supposed to be doing
I'm gonna find on page 80 as I always
find on page 85 said I am somewhere
between fifteen and twenty seven pages
too long you know and there will be that
moment and that's like this inevitable
moment it almost never doesn't happen
and when the fear outstrips your
confusion at that moment I will make
those cuts and I don't know how long I
ran did I hit my half an hour and we are
done
[Applause]
you mentioned earlier your dad is a
Pulitzer prize-winning playwright
novelist screenwriter worked in TV and
he didn't want any of his children to
work in the business you're a
screenwriter your brother's a
screenwriter your other brother isn't
editor is storytelling and we obviously
that didn't work his storytelling kind
of genetic did you have conversations
around the dinner table when you were
young about storytelling meaning I guess
so it wasn't a conscious thing I mean he
moved us to a random place where we
would grow up so we wouldn't grow up in
that I mean we grew up as far away as
you could possibly grow up so we had no
connection with it whatsoever I mean I
suppose it's you know if you grow up in
a you know in a pineapple factory you're
gonna know something about pineapples
that's how we lived and the tempo of a
writer's life and the disappointments of
a writer's life and the exultation of a
writer's life and you know being being
really high on the hog and being broke
and every other thing so the life of it
wasn't afraid I don't know about the
storytelling I admit I don't know if
it's genetics or not you talked about
the the the idea of sort of finding
sorry the process of finding an idea
it's kind of digging a tunnel of digging
a hole and finding the idea right and
you said that you believe there are
three days of kind of inspiration that
pay for the entire year is that yeah I
mean there are I mean you yeah I think
that's really true I mean there's just
there's just nothing happens and
everything just sucks and nothing's
right and you all of a sudden there's a
day where like oh my god that's it
that's the whole that's the whole movie
where the movie drops where something
epic really happens and you're just like
holy [ __ ] that's the whole thing and
that is the day that you will base
you'll build a temple around what you
did inspirationally in that hour you
will now spend your next six months
building the building around that idea
and around that moment and it's but you
have to be there right okay we're gonna
throw it open to you do you think it's
helpful to use formulas like the hero's
journey
Campbell to to help you to move your
blood along go to do the first screen
now again I think it's like like I said
before I think it's more forensic I
think it has to be instinctive I think
you go back and look and go oh what did
I do
oh that's what I did that's what how
this worked I think you know that
everybody here's been going to movies
you've been sucking up narrative since
you were born
you've grew up in a culture that has you
not have to tell fields you don't have
to like go bang stones together to clean
your clothes you have all this leisure
time and you filled it with narrative
and food right what is the cumulative
number of stories that this audience has
watched and looked at you know more
about storytelling then you know about
almost anything probably your families I
mean it's really astonishing
you know instinctively what a movie
looks like it's always astonishing
people give you a script I wrote my
script I think it it's like did you ever
see a [ __ ] movie how did you write
it's like you know what it looks like
you know what it feels like you don't
need to Joseph Campbell to tell you what
a hero's journey is you know what it is
it's it's it's already way down deep
inside he's writing about something he
says is deep inside you before you even
knew about it so um you have all that
you don't need you don't need you don't
need that help it's great confirmation
when you're you know when you're lost
and you want you're trying to
procrastinate and that the books in your
office is like oh well I've done that so
I'm I want to be like I don't want to
sound too cool for the room I've have a
copy of it and I've looked through it
but it doesn't he said during the talk
and you get friends coming up to you
asking how to write great action scenes
and I wondered what do you tell them
all right this is this is a good
question to finish on because it sort of
touches into what we talked about before
it really is as I said before what you
know and what you see and I cannot write
an action sequence that I can write you
know you can totally I mean there's a
couple times I've typed things because
directors have asked you to just turn in
something twice I've done that but if
I'm gonna write an action sequence
I have it has to be real it has to be a
real place unborn for every single one
of the films before well the identity
were all locations that I knew I knew
every single by new Paris really well
and I knew every you know I knew knew
everything about this who I was writing
into stuff I knew when we went to do
supremacy as I was writing the script
while they were just placeholders for
the action-packed Crowley and Frank
Marshall and I long before the script
was written visit Berlin spent a week in
Moscow all those sequences were built
absolutely to the locations oh my god
here's the market oh my god what if he
grabs vodka and oh there's a cab and
this is what a great place for car chase
what a great place in Berlin to jump
from the bridge whatever on legacy you
know went to the Philippines three times
before we shot all of those action
sequences are completely built exactly
to those locations you build it for
where it is you go there you see it you
deal with the limitations of it it's not
what's so great about it but what's
wrong with it what what makes it what
will make things go wrong what will make
things be contained what haven't I seen
before oh my god this this is this is
really tough here this would be really
hard and this is I've never seen this
before it's what's eccentric and wrong
about things it's the limitations of
things that make them specific and make
them interesting and how to do it in a
place that you haven't really visited or
isn't really real to you or you don't
understand
and trying to write action if you don't
understand how gravity works or
understand what a derrick does or what a
ferris wheel
I mean if if you don't understand the
physical world you're at another
limitation
but the more specific and and the more
real it is to you that's the key to to
getting into all of it and then on the
page translate it onto the page on the
page all right I have everything I've
been putting it off for we could sort of
like a it's sort of like a bullfight
it's kind of like you've been putting
and I sorta like giving it speech like
putting it off putting it off putting it
off I know other things I sort of think
and it's like finally I can't not wait
anymore and it's like 14 cups of coffee
and anything else it'll help you do it
and you sit down and you try to do it as
fast as possible anything that will help
it's the one time I'll really party when
I write I mean cuz you really want to
just get it all down and energized as
much as possible Donnie does it send you
this is that this is it she's there and
she jumps and this is he really wants to
feel you want to feel like the thing you
want to get pumped up you know you want
to be I haven't written a lot of sex
scenes which I'm assuming is the same
thing that's next on that note please
put your hands together
Teddy girl right
[Music]
you
[Music]